now earlier i mentioned that
from a macro perspective the pyramids
aren't particularly interesting as
structural systems
but there is one noteworthy exception to
this rule
the maidum pyramid
if you visit the maidum pyramid today
you'll see what appears to be a step
pyramid surrounded by an enormous pile
of rubble
how did it get that way well let's start
with some background
the earliest egyptian pyramids were step
pyramids like this one
dating from the third dynasty around
2640 bc
the maidon pyramid was a typical step
pyramid
fought to have been originally
constructed by the pharaoh huni
around 2630 bc but
fashions changed and huni's successor
decided to convert the maidon pyramid
from a step pyramid to a true pyramid by
filling in the steps with a limestone
casing
this diagram shows the revised
configuration
since the 1800s most scholars have
believed that the ruined condition that
we see at maidum today
was caused by theft of that casing stone
according to this theory subsequent
builders used the maiden pyramid as a
quarry
removing that high quality limestone
casing material and leaving only the
rubble behind
but in the 1970s a german-born physicist
named
kurt mendelsohn provided an intriguing
alternative hypothesis
mendelssohn calculated the volume of
debris surrounding the midam pyramid
and he found that it was roughly equal
to the volume of the missing
casing stone this suggests
quite convincingly i would say that the
debris at the base of the pyramid
is the casing and therefore it must be
the result of a catastrophic collapse
rather than theft
so what caused the collapse
mendelssohn's investigation showed that
when the outer casing was added to the
step pyramid
it was placed on its own foundation
composed of large stones that were
placed directly on desert sand
rather than on bedrock it was built with
horizontal layers of masonry
in contrast to the inner core of the
pyramid
where the masonry layers are sloped
inward to improve their stability
so it's very likely that the casing
foundation settled because it was
resting on sand
and that settlement caused the casing to
separate from the rest of the pyramid
once this happened the lower portion of
the casing would have suddenly had to
carry a much greater compressive load
the weight of the entire casing above it
and could easily have buckled outward
just like a column
this failure would have brought the
remainder of the casing down in one
massive landslide of limestone creating
a pile of rubble very similar to the one
we see today
that soft foundation as well as the
horizontal masonry configuration
could also have made the casing far more
vulnerable to
destruction by an earthquake say and we
actually know that earthquakes are
fairly common in this region
indeed there are three tectonic plates
intersecting nearby
further corroborating evidence of
mendelssohn's theory can be seen in the
famous
bent pyramid of dashur which was started
while the maidum pyramid was still under
construction
the bend pyramid was initially built
with its sides sloped at the standard 52
degree angle
that we see in nearly all the pyramids
but midway through construction as you
can see in the photo
the slope was abruptly changed to a
shallower angle
43 and a half degrees an adjustment that
would have reduced its weight
and increased its stability then
next another pyramid was constructed
it was called the red pyramid located at
dashur
and it is the only other pyramid in
egypt to be built with an angle of 43.5
degrees that shallower more stable angle
so based on this chronology it seems
very likely that
first the casing of the maiden pyramid
collapsed
then the builders of the bent pyramid
fearing that the same problem would
occur in their own construction
changed the angle of its sides to
improve its stability
and then the builders of the red pyramid
followed the same convention
and constructed the entire structure at
the safer 43.5 degree angle
subsequently egyptian builders must have
determined that the fundamental cause of
the mydom collapse was its unsound
foundations
because all subsequent pyramids were
built at the original 52 degree angle
but they were founded on solid bedrock
so is mendelson's theory correct we'll
probably never know
but it's entirely plausible and it
certainly demonstrates
once again that an engineering
perspective opens the door to new
insights about our world